welcome to another ideas that matter
conversation I'm really delighted here
to have a young colleague who I've
interacted with at a lot of Aristotle
and the Aristotelian tradition
conferences so this is Usha Nathan from
Louis Louisiana State University where
she is a professor and she's got a lot
of areas of specialization that I think
are going to be very helpful for people
who don't
um know what's going on in contemporary
philosophy so we're going to talk about
this term epistemic
Injustice and about moral emotions but
we're going to do so not from a let's
call it presentist perspective but a
much longer view because uh Usha is also
a specialist in Aristotle and we've
talked quite a lot about um you know the
emotions and the the role that they play
in Aristotle and in ancient philos phos
ophy more broadly so welcome an and why
don't we just jump right in uh I think
that the term uh epistemic Injustice and
you've also got another term that you
use in in a paper hermeneutic Injustice
these are um these are topics
terminology that a lot of people see out
there but they don't have a clear idea
of what they mean so can you I'm not
asking for a definition because those
are always hard to come by but can you
characterize what these are so that
people can wrap their head around them
yeah so um you know simplest way to put
it is to say Injustice that you suffer
in your status as a
knower uh some uh as someone who has
some knowledge that is or you're in your
capacity as a noer uh that sort of
Injustice is characterized as epistemic
Injustice so that's just sort of um you
know
um it sounds mysterious so let's give an
example the the Miranda frer who coins
this phrase and she wrote the book
epistemic Injustice where she sort of
classifies it into two categories so one
is testimonial Injustice and the other
ones have manical Injustice uh the more
straightforward one is testimonial and
that's just simply um uh we can think of
cases where a person is not trusted as a
nor and the classic sort of examples you
can think of is um you know
antibellum
um um America you know the laws would
not permit African-Americans to give
evidence um and they would not be
trusted as sources of knowledge so these
were that's that's an example and you
know um more controversial we can say
that given the rape laws that exists
today even today women are not trusted
as um you know as knowledgeable about
the incidents they suffer so we need to
often when they give testimony about um
sexual violence that case needs to be
established on Independent evidence
often because their testimony their
evidence giving is not taken um it's not
considered credible enough uh on its own
and so those kinds of injustices and you
know what has been interesting and why
the term sort of took off I think is
that it immediately sort of captures a
very core problem which which people um
especially you know gender uh
discrimination cases and um you know
racial Injustice cases and you know more
broadly we can say uh you know refugees
who have to prove um or Asylum Seekers
who have to prove um you know that they
are indeed uh you know targets say they
you know live in their Asylum seers that
prove that they are targets that their
life is in danger so you can look at all
of these kinds of instances and you see
so the testimonial Injustice term
captures so much of what is happening um
you know narrowly in the legal context
but you can see more broadly as a social
phenomenon um you know that be that as
knowers marginalized persons tend to not
be trusted in their capacities as
knowers and their evidence is not taken
as credible and so um that's one of the
reasons that it's so it's spoken to a
broad range of Scholars not just
philosophers but it's really pulled in I
think a um um a lot of attention from a
lot of people working on these areas um
in you know legal Theory and law and but
also in other areas there these kinds of
issues are studied um and so um
testimonial Injustice which is a kind of
in fact maybe the most you know obvious
and prominent kind of epistemic
Injustice
um uh it has really I I think um uh you
know connected with Scholars in a lot of
fields um hermeneutical Injustice is
less studied I would say and it sounds
also you know because of the you know
multiable word there a little bit more
scary but I think to me it's more
fascinating in some ways because it's a
very subtle phenomenon which is is much
more likely to be missed so from tical
Injustice um uh frier has a very nice
way of characterizing it she calls it
the kind of Injustice where a person has
a um part of their experience that is uh
sort of
indescribable or unnamed unnamed is sort
of the official idea
unnamed um uh
for reasons having to do with um again
um you know the threat it poses to power
relations uh their position it has to do
with their position in society so um in
my paper for Ergo I look at uh one the
case that fricker looks at is the term
sexual harassment which for a long time
was not coined in fact it's so recent
that it's you know almost shocking that
the word didn't didn't exist before the
um you know um uh post feminism you know
first um feminism this uh so she talks
about the evolution of that term and she
talks about you know um one particular
case in you know
um uh we have to be careful it's not as
if it was not prevalent right that so
one of the things I I do in my paper is
I look at a c maybe a really AR archaic
example of that kind of harassment I
look at a play in escalus which is in
fact you know it's it's preclassical um
so you know the phenomenon has been
around ait's talked ton about it right
you know Aid's metamorphosis full of
instances of harassment um if you think
about it but uh the term has only been
coined very recently and so frier talks
about a case of a um specifically about
a case of a woman in in carnal who was
working in a lab of a famous uh
scientist who was um you
know um making sexual advances towards
her again and again uh and up to to a
point where she was you know forced to
take the stairs to avoid him having to
take the elevator with him um started
suffering all kinds of physical uh uh
problems you know uh back pain and all
sorts of things because of all the you
know extra things that she had to do to
just to maneuver to safety um and so she
finally quits her job but suddenly when
she's like
um she goes to file for unemployment
there's a problem there because the term
doesn't exist she's unable to say and
she has to write down personal reasons
and of course that's not that doesn't
qualify her right and so that's a
problem and um uh what then happens I
mean frer tells the story in a very
linear way I think Concepts don't evolve
quite in that way right but you know
it's it's a nice narrative because it
kind of tells like going from not
knowing to knowing it's a nice story so
you know let's suppose this is how it
happened and so what happens is the uh
is at that that time there's
Consciousness raising groups that are
being run by feminists uh in and around
itha and one of the women Farley uh
invites her to come to um a meeting that
she's having where other women are
present and narrate her
experience and there is uh so um uh she
comes in and she tells you know what
what she had been going through at work
and there's an aha moment every woman in
the room recognizes what she's talking
about they don't have a name for it but
they all know what she's talking about I
mean I'm a little bit up for an
exaggeration to say all but most of them
in the room have familiarity with that
phenomenon so then that becomes the
point at which the um you know the women
start Lyn Farley and other women who Who
present the feminist start you know
talking and like um you know discussing
among themselves and in an effort to
sort of I think it's an article for New
York Times They are forced to sort of
coin a term for it because they have to
say what it is and so they come up with
uh after discussion among themselves
they say well we want to talk about
sexual harassment and then so that's the
term is coined because there's there's a
sense that it is it's it's happening
something's happening and that can be
described different women are
experiencing it can it described of a
single term and but we missing the term
so they it has to be coined and sort of
brought into existence then of course
you know it's years before the laws
catch up and then you know we have
sexual harassment regulations and laws
being put into place so you know but for
all of that to happen a name needs to be
given to this phenomenon uh which is an
experience for these women which until
that point is
Indescribable in some ways in some ways
it's interesting because um in many
cases it would be not described or uh
from the vantage point of that that
culture that time
Indescribable but it it strikes me that
one of the struggles is also getting it
getting it not misdescribed right so if
we take sexual harassment for example um
the common response in the past and
unfortunately still in the present is
well you know boys will be boys right
which is a write off saying ah this is
just the way it is you could you could
substitute other linguistic
expressions like this is just the nature
of business and so getting people to say
no no that's that's a Mis description
here's a better description of what's
actually happening this is the the
appropriate one um yeah yeah so um uh
that's the part of it that's fascinating
to me right so I think what you're
talking about as a Mis description is
that before the term is coined it's not
recognized as normative right not
recognized as a wrong um you know it it
exists you know women talk about it and
then um you know it's as you said it's
sort of brushed off the carpet as not
you know
significant not significant morally um
not significant normatively not
something that needs to be done anything
about so that's one of the shifts that
happens right so I think
um so sexual harassment is tricky for
that reason and but I'm really
interested in these kinds of like what I
call moral uh wrongs which are missing
from the vocabulary so to speak so I'm
interested in sort of maybe a subset of
these hermeneutical cases You could
argue that all of them have a moral
Dimension they might it might be the
case that they at least have a normative
Dimension um the other case that pra
mentions is um postpartum depression
that's a medical term not so much moral
but before that it's just sort of this
vague phenomen and surrounding
motherhood which you know you know can
burn blame the uterus hysteria or
whatever and um up until the medical
community sort of recognize it as a
distinct phenomena and name it it exists
in this very um um it it exists in a way
it again we could say it's again
misdescribed right it could be described
as oh she's having you know this is a
hormonal reaction or this is some you
know um or whatever way of you know sort
of dismissing it and sort of writing it
off um there's it's
unclear that all concepts are moral but
there there's again there's the
normative Dimension there something's
wrong like some kind of deviation has
occurred something um it's an actual
case of a disorder and so um yeah post
prum depression is the other one that
she mentions um in my paper I talk about
forced marriage um as a as a um as a
missing term in Greek the in the in the
ancient Greek context um because if you
look and for different cultures the
idea uh of
um female
agency um uh it it doesn't Elevate for
uh you know feminism it's it's not
waiting on 19th century but there's you
know different at various times C ideas
of female agency um you know
uh arise as sort of resistance to the
phenomenon and one of them is I think
that in a lot of cultures back then
um now we talking Classical period
pre-classical even where marriage is
described as a transaction between two
families and the it's only the
permission so to speak of the father
this is also um perhaps in some
instances in the Old Testament um there
where it's you know not she moves and
some of the old rape lws to talk about
it in this way like she's a property of
the father and then she's the property
of the husband right um and so she's not
seen as an agent um so in the Greek
context the play uh that ASAS writes uh
it's called the suppliance it's very
very old but it wasn't um one of the
trilogies that was awarded the Dinia
Festival we lost the other two but it's
supposed to be the first in the trilogy
there are lots of unusual features about
it um uh which makes the play very very
contemporarily um fascinating um yeah um
beyond the issue of forc marriage I
think um oh and very briefly it's uh uh
these hundred women arrive U they they
are royal ro royal women from a family
in Egypt they have arrived at the shores
um um uh of of a Greek Kingdom and they
um and they and they want the king to
they're seeking Asylum that's how we
would describe it in
modern uh but they're also claiming that
they have a kind of ancient claim to the
Greek Land that because they have an
ancestral connection to to Greece
through uh mythology and they claim that
uh this woman EO which who was a um who
was an maros many many years ago was
sort of targeted you know picked by Zeus
and uh and Hera between the quarrel
between Hera and Zeus she's turned into
a cow and she's chased out of her lands
and she wanders she becomes sort of a
refugee um in modern terms and she
wanders away and then uh later she goes
and settles in Egypt and so they claim
to be descendants of someone who was
originally from that land so that's the
only sort
of but there's so many other interesting
aspects this is one of the few place in
tragedies in um existing that where
there's a chorus as a protagonist um one
of the few ones where it's a chorus of
women and it's and their protagonist
they are also uh visibly very unlike
Greeks which the king says well you seem
to be from Ethiopia or some far away
land like India so they are they are
visibly foreigners so it's a chorus of
foreign women okay yeah as protagonist
so it's a very fascinating play for
those reasons as well and it's striking
because a lot of the play is very
stagnant it's mostly an exchange right
the uh women have sort of a leader their
father is present who advises them on
how to speak to the king but the women
are you know make their case directly to
the king the father doesn't speak for
them there is again esas has done a
interesting move there and then the king
the women speak to the king and um you
know there's a range of question and
answer back and forth It's almost like
an assembly it's uh but it's happening
on the shores of Aros and they they're
trying to convince the king to you know
please and the King says eventually you
know what I can't make the decision here
I need to take this to the assembly but
you you know um uh if you know so he
deflects his responsibility but the
entire the bulk of the play is the women
are engaged in a a dialectic where back
and forth with the King trying to
persuade him to take up their case and
to speak up on their behalf at the
assembly they don't have a voice in the
assembly but the king can speak for them
so um how I uh yeah how I connected to
epistemic Injustice is day have this
trouble of speaking like you know
something's being done we need
protection this is wrong and the king is
obviously because there's no reason
right they keep he keeps challenging
them saying what are you saying did they
do something wrong according to the laws
of your country no yeah did they do
something wrong according to the land
land of arh no so what is the wrong
there and there's no so it's unclear
right so they keep saying a DK right so
they they are saying or hubris the uh
the term they use is hubris but they're
asking for justice they're asking for
Decay they're asking for justice but the
king is unable to see what the Injustice
is and so that's because women saying no
to their marriage is unheard of and and
so that's the situation where they are
forced to communicate something for
which the term doesn't exist the wrong
is not recognized as a wrong um and so
the the the persuasion then is sort of I
describe it as a kind of first
preliminary attempt at arriving at some
kind of communicative term um before you
know it's much later that it becomes you
know it's no nowhere near as clear as
the uh Linn Farley sexual harassment
case because there's no term coined but
the shift that happens in the play is
that the king is able to see the reasons
and he's a able to understand it as a
wrong and he's able he speaks in
language very strikingly similar to the
language that so the end of the plag
gets a little dramatic the King goes
away asks them to like stand inside the
um a temple there and you know you know
it's a Sacred Space there protected Zeus
is protector ironically Zeus is a
protector of
Outsiders right right yeah right so
there women are asked to stand inside
the temple and the King goes away and at
that time the um the cousins of these
women who are pursuing them are reach
the shores and there's a very visceral
moment where they're about to be dragged
out and taken away and the King comes
and he like stops them and says like
look you can't take them away and this
is why and there we finally see that
they have reached um communication has
succeeded he that he has reached a point
of some kind of transition of
understanding that no no no you you
can't do this and this is wrong and in
fact my citizens have agreed to protect
these women um so that so the play ends
with like the women being taken in um
and uh because the King goes and obtains
the permission of the assembly and comes
back and just in time to save the women
um so the to me what's fascinating about
the play is that the um the the main
action of the play is uh is is
rhetorical
uh it's a uh it's it's going from hey
something wrong is happening to me I
need someone to protect me you are the
king give me Justice and yeah the king
saying yes I think what is happening to
you is
Injustice so you know an interesting
segue that'll sort of broaden this there
another play that comes to mind where
the chorus is in fact a protagonist is
another by achelis uh the humanities
right because the the furies are the
chorus and they're so here's the
transition so your paper is is actually
titled um epis moral emotions and
unnamed wrongs revisiting epistemic
Injustice the furies are anger or
Vengeance personified you could say and
anger is one of these moral emotions
that we hear about and you've got a very
nice analysis in there about uh aristot
and And the emotions now anger is one of
those emotions that some philosophers
think oh it's always bad actually some
religious Traditions too you know uh
certain Christians you can see this in
in a lot of Buddhist interpretations ah
just don't don't do it but Aristotle
says that uh you know we have to watch
it don't uh automatically think that
getting angry is going to solve anything
but it could serve some useful purpose
so what are these moral emotions and you
know in your paper you say that moral
emotions can you know they can help us
realize that there's an epistemic
injustice taking place how does that
actually
work yeah uh thank you um so moral
emotions is a term I borrow from
contemporary philosophy I you know with
Aristotle and the Greeks it's
fascinating uh all emotions for
Aristotle moral we don't have to you
know spend too much time thinking about
it but you know uh it's because it's
because of the way they think about you
know fear which is often the case of a
non-moral emotion for us yeah but even
that is sort of considered um like
there's a kind of moral danger life is
morally important um and so the way
Aristotle conceives of it all of the
emotions have some kind of um moral
normative content but uh you know but as
contemporary philosophers see it and I
think you know our our way of thinking
about emotions at least some of our
emotions are moral
emotions um in the sense that they have
uh they have normative content they have
to do with um
recognizing or um recognizing is too
strong a word I I use awareness
awareness something wrong has occurred
um uh and that's where often the
negative emotions come in so this ties
in with your question so um are not all
of them are uh not all moral emotions
are negative but many of them are right
so anger is a very prominent case now
the way the Greeks um think about anger
which is sort of very close to how
Aristotle thinks about anger this is I'm
thinking about um you know
uh the the work of David conston on
Greeks and on emotions so um uh so
Aristotle is more or less with the
common sense there with the Greek sense
of of anger which is that it sort of
response to a
slight that that's very interesting way
that he describes it it's a response to
um
and uh interestingly he says
undeserved slight right undeserved
slight done to you or one of your own
and here the your own uh here the um um
that's also interesting is that it's not
just a personal thing it's also
something where your uh brother or your
immediate family or one of your close
friends friends are really important for
AR um is insulted you can be
angry because it's as if it's happened
to your extended self it's it's it's so
anger is a very personal emotion so a
lot of things that we call anger like
you know being angry for what is
happening um to uh to children in Gaza
for instance those kinds of cases
Aristotle wouldn't really call them
anger so those are cases we describe as
anger um that might be you know um it's
hard to say exactly what they would be
they would be sort of like um not
exactly nemesis but something like
indignation Nemesis is translated as
indignation it's it it's somewhere
between what aristal calls anger and
what Aristotle um and the Greeks call
Nemesis or indignation so those kinds of
cases are not even anger fire so anger
is a very personal emotion but it is
tied to this normative notion because it
has to do with an undeserved slight so
for Aristotle it's important uh it's an
important way of
um uh of standing up for
yourself and so the in his and those
that you care about as well yeah those
that you care about um
so uh so it's easy for him you know
because it is described as his
undeserved slight and it has to do with
you know a one social standing a slight
is when you're treated in in in an
inferior way um by uh a peer or someone
lower or someone higher but you know in
it it has again this is interesting for
for the Greeks that all the Greek all
the Greek emotions are very have a very
strong social aspect to them even anger
does and anger has to do with it you
know how someone's treating you and how
they should be treating you we think of
that as just moral but for the Greeks
it's also social and so the it's uh
aristal it's easy step from there to say
well if you don't show sufficient anger
or you don't show anger in the
situations where you're where it is
appropriate to show anger you're in fact
and um you know not responding
appropriately that's a lack that's a
lack of virtue right and that's a that's
a failure that's um that's an app um
that shows and if uh it's those kinds of
cases are in fact uh you know it most
people would agree those are you know
that you've you you have failed to
respond appropriately in those
situations that's the way that for
Aristotle anger becomes an appropriate
emotion and you know where this light is
undeserved and so on and um the so where
the respones as AR as aristan Scholars
would say where anger is called for you
should exhibit um anger now where it
gets a little bit hard and this is where
I think people have a the the religious
tradition and a lot of other Traditions
depart from Aristotle is that aristol
recognizes that part of anger anger is a
mixed emotion parol there's a kind of
pain right you being you're being
treated badly that part is painful but
Aristotle says there's also an
anticipation of Revenge that's Pleasant
very pleasant yeah in his feel and um
you know uh as
happy to admit it and it it's not to say
that he's condoning the pursuit of that
Revenge it's just he's recognizing what
a natural sort of aspect of anger is
that you are also anticipating that
future Revenge which which is an
anticipatory pleasure you're imagining
getting back at this guy which is yeah
and for Aristotle it that part is
unpraised
um um doesn't sort of don't you think
that like the you know getting angry in
the right way at the right time with the
right person all these sort of provisos
that go into the anger being um virtuous
being part of proud or good temper
mildness um doesn't that give us kind of
a a check on it now people get mixed up
about it and there's the possibility of
like lying to yourself and your friends
and saying oh I'm totally justified and
and me uh keying this person's car or
spray painting something on their door
is that's the right way to handle these
sorts of things right people can get
mixed up about that but then Aristotle
would come along and be like come on
buddy you you know that's not the the
right sort of thing to do yeah yeah I
think yeah those are definitely sort of
the cases are much more restricted so he
written okay our common you know you can
have an angry response whether or not
it's a appropriate that so Aristotle has
um in another paper that is is under
review I talk more about Aristotle has
very strict uh sort of dimensions of uh
each emotion that you know to have the
appropriate respones not just in this
moment anger is called for and you have
the angry response no aristal further
wants to say it should be directed at
the right person or situation it has to
be of the appropriate intensity so you
know if you're someone who's like
someone shoves you and you're like you
know you get murderous angry you know
obviously off right I'm exaggerating but
arist is very very you know careful
about saying like the response should be
appropriate proportional or in not
proportional but of the appropriate
intensity it should be held for the
right amount of time so right Asal
interestingly talks about all the
various ways in which you can go wrong
so you can be
just someone who's like who tends to
hang on to anger too much it's just a
bitter tempered person that's a way of
like getting your anger it's like your
um disposition for anger is by itself is
vicious right like you're disposed to be
too angry or to you you're disposed
sorry you're disposed to be angry for
too long for things even if those things
are appropriate to be angry about if
you're angry for too long that's in way
of
failing to have the appropriate response
so to to add another wrinkle to this and
come back to the idea of epistemic
Injustice and moral emotions being ways
that we can maybe like breach that
whatever resistance there is so imagine
a situation where you you've got a
person who's in a higher up position a
person who's in a lower up position
we'll just say it's in the workplace
right so it's it's it's and we we'll
take race and gender and all that out of
it it's just a pure power Rel
and the um the boss is doing things that
are should make a person angry they're
and they're and they're doing it in
terms of epistemic Injustice they they
want to do a policy the employee says
that's going to negatively impact us and
here's how it's going to affect us and
the boss says well what would you know
you're not in charge you don't have an
MBA pick whatever excuse you want and
then the employee gets angry as a result
rightly so I would say um and let's say
that they're actually you know they're
exhibiting it in the right way instead
of like um going and and kicking the
boss's door in and knocking everything
off their desk like they do in the
movies they write a strongly worded memo
you know and it goes to the boss and the
boss is you know like well your anger is
inappropriate in this case I'm sending
you to HR because of this you have anger
problems so you know who gets to decide
the the measures we could say for um you
know the right amount of intensity over
the right thing expressed in the right
way it it's a different it's not
epistemic Injustice at that point
although epistemic Injustice was the
let's say the cause of that um but it's
another kind of Injustice for me if I'm
the boss to dismiss the employee or it
could be teacher and student you know to
dismiss their um their reaction as oh
you're you're you know you don't know
you're an uncultivated you're vicious or
something like that I think that's what
now if we transpose that into race class
gender ability pick whatever else we
want where there are structural
inequalities like that I think we see
that a lot right where women get angry
over you know the fact that people
aren't taking sexual harassment
seriously and then they're they're
talked about as being shrill or
hysterical or pick a you know whatever
list of terms you like right yeah
uh um that's a phenomenon that's more
people are talking about it now it it's
a kind of affective oppression okay
that's not the term in the literature
but that's how I would describe it it's
okay there a kind of yeah so the Norms I
I think what we are talking about here
is that there are they are there are
certain um unfair Norms that uh uh that
ctail the expression especially of
negative emotions of persons in
marginalized position okay and they are
sort of self- policing themselves um and
often you know um uh that's a kind of
Injustice in on its own and uh on a
picture of AR so the marit of arol
picture is that we can make sense of
that because you know uh at the
and here I'll come to a worry that you
have shared with me about aristo's views
about women in a moment so yeah there is
this um you know um in the discussion of
Virtues at least Aristotle is not um
differentiating the virtues of a a
man
um um depending on economic class right
so there's no you know that anger is
inappropriate I think he would though
say that given his views about slavery
uh that there are certain emotions that
are inappropriate um for so aristol
picture would become restrictive there
but here's where I think what
um here's where things are interesting
for me with Aristotle is that I think
the um
his uh his views are in tension with
each other that's the way in which I
understand him there are people who
think um and here marasa
uh uh Marisa uh Leen um at North
Carolina Chapel Hill she has worked in
aristal biology she has a read on
aristal ethics as you know assuming
already from the get-go that this is
only for a certain class of ethic you
know uh of of men in Greek society you
know that's I think that's a way of
making him consistent with his
biological views with his views in the
politics but I read Aristotle as
inconsistent and yeah and I think to
underdetermined you could say right
underdetermined and I think there is a
genuine in incoherence and I think
there's similar issues with his
epistemology you can try to render it
consistent and I think there we are not
doing him Justice by doing that and not
seeing his own intellectual sort of
pitfalls but Parts where his certain of
his intellectual aspirations get the
better of him yeah yeah and then he
fails to recognize that they don't they
don't conform to his very parochial
views about women slavery and so on so
that's how I Le him um uh in his ethics
for instance right to the there are
moments of like genuine uh I think
Insight where he's not at least in the
ethics he's not very um concerned about
you know is this applicable to every
culture every are we talking about non-
Greeks also are we talking about but why
does he not do that so either you could
say and this is where I and Maris
disagrees either you could say he's
presupposing he's only talking to Greek
Noble right the the Greek well-born
gentleman or you could say that he
thinks that uh you know um these are
just the right ethical views and these
are the view this is his not that he is
necessarily coming up with an ethical
Theory I don't think he there is the
ethics yields a single Theory as a whole
but he is trying to get it right I think
that's the way I read him so his ethics
I think uh stands in in tension with his
Politics As I and so but there is the
problem uh given how he thinks about the
minds so he thinks his biological views
are that right women are incapable of
practical wisdom slaves are incapable
natural slaves are incapable practical
wisdom so they are um uh so they they
will lack virtues right so they'll not
have full virtue because full virtue
requires practical wisdom so they cannot
have full virtue that's the view we get
very much in the politics and uh and and
the rhetoric I would say too where where
he most people are bad you know most
people are bad yeah the
rhetoric there are uh you know further
challenges some people think it may not
even be his philosophical Theory you
know there there's some more
controversies with how to read his
rhetoric than there there is with his
ethics so there's that problem but you
know I think what the ethical Theory as
if if if as I'm thinking it truly
aspires at least to get it right it
applies to everyone and in if that's the
case then his theories are intention and
uh and but but I think that's where
interestingly it yields some of these uh
you know you can sort of use Aristotle
to criticize Aristotle so to speak yes
that's a great way to put it I think
yeah yeah yeah so
that's how I I I try to make sense of
that but um there's uh I haven't
addressed everything in your question
but I think um that that's part of the
idea behind I find that in
interpretation that approach to very
attractive because it it makes Aristotle
no longer into the Superhuman Sage that
we all have to listen to and you know
he's like the rest of us we're you know
we're kind of a mess of contradictions
um if I look back at my own works you
know they don't all add up uh in in
relation to each other the more that I
write probably the more that's the case
but I do want to I want to bring up
another question I because I want to be
you know uh cognizant of of your time um
so this has to do with moral emotions
and it has to do with the standpoint so
I can talk about my own moral emotions
revealing to me that uh an epistemic
injustice is taking place you think
about young younger people being
dismissed by older people for example
right and the same thing happens now
with older people I'm getting to
experience this the older I get older
people being dismissed by by younger
people younger people um but I think
that in a lot of cases it wouldn't be so
much that I have the moral emotion but
rather I perceive another person having
the moral
emotion as being a sign that there's
something wrong so we've talked about
anger and you mentioned fear if I so
let's say we take refugees or anybody
else who's in a very vulnerable position
they have very few resources and I see
them being uh interrogated by a police
officer and I and the fear that they
have is palpable you can you can sense
it you know in in the air so to speak
and you're like wow something's
happening here and you see the police
officer being oppressive and dismissive
towards them or it could be a bureaucrat
or pick whoever you want you know and
like oh wow there's there's something
wrong here I can't put my finger on it
but I I know there's something that that
is happening because of the emotional
reaction of the other person and it
could be anger and I was wondering well
what other moral emotions could maybe
sadness grief you know that a person
feels where you're like oh man I don't
know what's what's going on but I know
there's something substantive here um I
need to identify if Y what this is or at
least touch on the surface so that I can
do justice to this this other person in
relation to whoever is causing them you
know to feel
this um yeah
so there's couple things I want to say
about it first thing I want to say which
relates to your earlier question and um
um this is where I challenge figures
account uh and others have done it too
um
um and uh you
know uh the problem with freers account
is that there's a kind of to clean uh a
kind of like one step you know you go
from not knowing and there's a term
that's it's over but I think often what
happens is that there's a like usually
there's multiple stages and there's also
some you uh it's not something that is
uh you know it's either up to the person
suffering the situation or it's like you
know ORS they have to like wait for some
big change to happen for it's not those
kinds of um uh it's not top down it's
and it's it is sort of bottom up but
also it's not that simple and so often
it is up to the victims to somehow
recognize something is wrong and what
happens is as you are describing um
they are there are third parties who are
sympathetic um onlookers who are you
know they are they are not in the same
situation as the victims as the king in
the story they're not in the same
situation as the victims and they are
not in any reason for any reason
sympathetic to the U to the to the
aggressors or the oppressors so um they
may be in in a pos position of relative
privilege but what
what is interesting is that the there is
a sense of and this is what I talk about
in the paper is that there's a sense in
which they understand from a broad from
our Broad and sort of in uh what we
might even call an intuitive sense of in
of Justice I call that um you know
there's a kind of um
preconceptual uh you know just there's a
sense almost of Injustice that people
pick up on so that's kind of sense
allows sympathetic third parties to
recognize just as you're describing when
you witness someone being questioned Say
by a person at the border or some
somebody being questioned by the police
you can recognize you can feel that
something is wrong so that I think
um that's
the those people play a crucial role and
um they can often be um uh sort of
appealed to so they you know to
uh one of the problems that Freer raises
and this goes back to something You'
mentioned right so the problem often
people mention is that how can the
marginalized person communicate right
because they are often not allowed to
express their emotions right how can
they communicate what they feel at a
very affective level that anger or this
visceral sense of wrong or shame often
victims of sex harm feels shame so how
do they communicate that that thing
that's happening to them so and uh what
I talk about in the paper is that one
rhetoric is a kind of it's an old idea
uh coming from the Greek tradition it's
a bad word now but if you think about it
purposeful use of language right like
writers do with when they use
description thick description evocative
description in novels and so on
fiction that kind of use of language can
actually be used as a tool as as a as a
to communicate um so that's one of the
uh things that we see happening in the
play is that they use mythology they use
analogy to communicate their situation
to the King right the king is familiar
with the myth of e he understands
something you know terribly wrong
happened to this poor woman turned into
a cow and made to wander the Earth right
so they're tapping into that knowledge
and that U familiarity and they are
using an analogy to draw him in and to
communicate that like Hey look you see
that someone something really terrible
happened to her we are wandering like
her we are wandering away from we are
being forced to leave our land and we
are come here so there's they can
communicate that uh so one it's rhetoric
and the other is that that you know you
don't need sexual harassment all you
need there is you know a way of
eliciting the sense of wrong that the
King has there's this broader Notions of
justice and fairness that we all have
from uh you know from being part of
society and uh you know just you know
navigating life pick up um that notion
of fair sense of fairness and Justice
which allows us to recognize that it's a
wrong it doesn't have a name it's still
a wrong so there's already progress
there and those that's the kind of thing
that is interesting to me so I think
you're right but the other thing I
wanted to say about it was that this
here's something that I do think here
I'm going well beyond Aristotle I think
but what I sort of learned from Audrey
Lord and reading James Baldwin who I'm
I'm a big fan of um both is pros and
fiction um is that there is you know
um uh and feminists have a way of making
sense of it they talk about how is it
that they the uh
victim experiences the wrong and
recognizes the wrong before the
oppressor does right so the there's a
sense of like asymmetry there right okay
yeah there's an asymmetry there and um
early feminist uh epistomology they talk
about you know because the oppressed is
in a position of constantly being you
know in a situation of as you described
they're vulnerable they're vulnerable to
harm so
they often are and Balvin would describe
it in this way in a situation where they
have more knowledge of their oppressor
than the oppressor themselves right
right and so they are very aware of
their actions they I often anticipate
their responses they
so it it it it's a situation of being
vulnerable so it is as a kind of
survival mechanism you might call it uh
but the Balman talks about this as a
kind of very immediate sense that you
get of like oh yeah
before other people sense the wrong they
can sense you know this is wrong and and
that I think is is a product of that
vulnerability and that's what we learned
from Lord Audrey Lords actually use her
in the paper because she gives I saw
yeah yeah it's a retrospective
description of her as a 5-year-old when
she for the first time um you know comes
face to face with racial hate um and
she's you know you know we had to be
cautious about like how well you
remember what you remember as a of your
experience as a 5-year-old but you know
there's a to me what was fascinating was
she there's a small detail in it which
captures beautifully again there's an
analogy she the girl gets is on a subway
um in in Harlem and she gets in and a
lady gets in in a very f coat and this
5-year-old little audre Lord is is a
little 5-year-old and you know so far
she has never like so far hasn't
encountered hate uh of racial hate and
so she's sitting next to this woman and
this woman sort of pulling herself away
from her like trying to take her Cod
away from her and immediately her
response is is there a cockroach here
the child looks to see oh is there a is
there something here something here that
is causing her to have it's a kind of
reaction almost there's a pest something
you want to get you know that kind of a
verion that this woman is exhibiting
that the child picks up that's the only
aspect of it that she's able to pick up
it was later that she recognizes that
what what was actually being that's her
yeah it's she's feeling the aversion
towards her not there's no insect it's
her that she's feeling the abion for and
you know um and of course Lord is
constructing a kind of narrative where
she says there are other instances where
she sees that you know um when she goes
to a chemist or something there's
another incident in a shop and she sees
like something same thing in that
person's eyes you know that's so she
can what is interesting to me is that um
and I'm unclear if like um um let's
first instance you know grant that
there's at least
this uh there's some kind of probab
um sort of evolution of a concept and we
would think you know what what like
concepts are difficult to describe a lot
of models now exist for what is a
concept so we don't have to worry about
any of that but at the very least right
we we think someone has a concept and
they can pick out the things instances
of it right so if I don't have the
concept of a cup I'd call it I don't
know yeah the bowl with my coffee in it
or something right so and if you ask me
to go get a cup I wouldn't know cuz I
didn't know which what is cup in the
kitchen so if you know how to pick it
out that's the first maybe indication or
very
basic uh it may not be sufficient for
for saying I have a concept but that's
one of the steps so um so when the child
recognizes I call it like her picking up
like an aspect of racial hate when she
notices the aversion and then she makes
the connection that it's not the roach
it's her that so she's picked out
something and when she's able to see
other instances of it that's her able to
it's it's almost exhibiting like a a
precon I call it a preconceptual
awareness because most people wouldn't
say that's enough for a concept but
there's a kind of awareness so that's
all it takes is to be able to identify
an aspect of something and then if
you're able to see the same thing happen
in a few instances then you're um the
way it relates to Aristotle and in some
ways for me all of this in some ways
comes out of Aristotle's theory of moral
learning because Aristotle says we um we
develop responses before we acquire
Concepts so right
right uh so you know before knowing why
something is right or being able to give
the reason why something is right we
learn to identify that that's the right
thing to do right like if if there's
someone being it feels right it feels
right yeah yeah yeah so it's like you
know if someone's like beating if you're
you know kindergarten a kid is you see a
a kid getting beaten you have nothing to
do with a kid it's not a friend nothing
but you imediately say hey hey don't do
that right so it's not like maybe the
child have a reason and now we have
people who are working in uh development
of psychology who are you know working
on I seeing then we can say there's like
some kind of moral concept and not just
like you know it's wrong because it's um
unacceptable in our society so there's a
there but they're now slowly starting to
see that there is this distinct sense
that even toddlers have um evolve a kind
of ability to say something is wrong or
respond to it as wrong they can give the
reasons for it reasons come later and
that's an Aristotelian Insight I think
he that's what he says is habituation
comes first so Iden being able to sort
of sense that it's the wrong thing and
then being able to respond in that in
that way that just saying that is a
first response and then doing something
about stopping it so those things come
first and then we get you know a deeper
moral understanding on on the picture so
if you think about it all I'm saying is
that take the Aristotle picture right
and if you think about it there's a lot
that you don't know and we can't really
say that our moral learning is complete
at any stage um oh yeah right and so we
might think that we continue to learn in
that way same way that aristal things
habituation occurs at various stages in
our life and it somehow takes that kind
of slow path from response to um
reasoning and reflective understanding
something like that path has to happen
um even for the other uh even for even
for adults and so um that's why so we
can walk around and see unnamed wrongs
just happen to be there I don't have a
theory about that um not yet at least
yeah Philip kitcher does um yeah about
you know how societies evolve uh into
you know better societies and so on you
know that raises a very interesting
thing which maybe we'll we'll conclude
so you are a what they often call Young
career academic right you're you're
fairly recently out of graduate school
you've got you've got a position um
you're exploring in very competent ways
that that I I like quite a bit um I
think important topics but you know if
we think about you said you don't have a
theory for this and maybe 20 years from
now you do right because these sorts of
things um aren't the types of matters
that you know it jumps out of our head
like Athena coming out of the the head
of Zeus it takes a long long time for us
to put all the different pieces together
and and uh sort them through and and
figure them out um so actually let me
ask you this sort of jumping off of that
um you've got interesting uh matters
that you're digging into using the
resources of both contemporary and uh
ancient philosophy and also doing
comparative work um is there something
on the horizon for you
that you haven't really worked out yet
but you're
really puzzled by and and do want to
start digging into more uh a re I won't
call it a research program because a
research program is like sort of like
pre-concept and concept as you were
talking about a research program you've
got it all worked out you can submit it
for Grants and tell people about it do
you have some incoit thing that you feel
is really important that you want to
work on
B um
uh funny thing is I have been so someone
recently did ask me because I have
something that I'm working on on
Aristotle which
is a sounds a lot different from all the
things that I'm working on in Puzzles
but um I've been trying to see so you
know um the way I think about it is that
we pursue these puzzles which capture us
the connections between them emerge
slowly but I'm trying to see the so let
me put it in the this way um the
connection recently I was listening to
George Saunders at an interview and he
he has a nice way of putting putting
this puzzle which to me really uh he he
calls it so he was describing his
writing process and he was he was saying
you know writers are often asked like
what is the method how do you come up
with it like what and you know you could
ask that same thing of philosophers I
don't think there is a linear neat
process from idea to paper um it's often
much more messy and so he was saying to
me um let's say like he says like it's
very difficult because it but he put it
as a puzzle he said this should be
puzzling to us that I can work on
something like a story which has like a
million moving parts right and um it's
like a Rubik's Cube It's like a very big
Rubik Cube puzzle and every small change
that I make right there are million
possibilities again I could have done it
you know did a different thing the story
would have gone different direction how
many million pieces and then he says but
I'm making these decisions the not all
of them are conscious so he calls it the
puzzle is um that it seems like are he
says like for a lack of better word the
unconscious is capable of
this massive amount of complexity that's
amazing and me that's an
completely um untouched phenomenon I
wouldn't call it untouched it's being
touched by Freud in bad ways um I won't
say all bad right unconscious get a b
gets a bad rap but you know the way I
call it and connects to how I think
about emotions is that there's this
um unsaid un sayable or as yet
inarticulate understandings and to
me um I'm encountering that I used the
first place I I think I talk about it is
where the um with the emotion stuff
there's but that's a broader phenomenon
and doesn't have just have to do with
art as Saunders describes it seems like
something to do with creativity it it
yes it's a puzzle also of creativity but
I think think there something
fascinating about the human mind that um
philosophers Overlook I'm fascinated by
it because it's such a widespread
phenomenon and it's a at least for me
because I'm fascinated with literature
and art it comes to me as a primarily as
an art puzzle but you know is there an
Ethics uh in EM motion stuff I'm seeing
it in in in uh um you know theories in
uh of racial Justice how how people came
to Consciousness and you know Evolution
if you see of con important Concepts in
racial Justice are happening in that way
um where this uh
unspoken un you know it's either
preverbal or it's you know maybe
non-conceptual or a conceptual I don't
know what it is but there seems to be
this um almost like beneath the tip of
the iceberg this entire phenomenon of
compl lexity that the human mind is
capable of uh that is I think my primary
puzzle
is coming at it I think um right now I'm
trying to come at it um from I'm still
coming at it from concept like trying to
understand in terms of
concept but I'm also constantly trying
to think about it from the creativity
perspective but I think I'm coming at it
in different ways but the phenomenon and
I can't couldn't find a better way than
sers to describe it it's just it seems
like um we are capable it's not just our
conscious mind is the part of it that is
below our understanding below our
reflective understanding is capable of
massive levels of complexity and that uh
is fascinating to me and something that
I want to you know try to yeah yeah kind
of develop some way of talking about it
and um come at it in different ways I
think that's that's that's what I'm
working on I don't think it's the puzzle
for a lifetime or I don't know I don't
want to call it to be like you're write
a whole sequence of books with you know
a quadrilogy or something about yeah
yeah but it seemed like I'm coming at it
now in a different way but I'm still
thinking essentially about that I I
think this is this is a great um Pro
whatever you want to call it problem
issue set of topics to to be fascinated
by
so yeah yeah thank you yeah so this this
has been a delight um thanks so much for
for coming on I think that that uh a lot
of the things that we've ranged over
will be very helpful for the people who
watch or listen to this so um I'll
include links to to all of the relevant
things your position the paper that we
referenced and anything else that you'd
like in the the
video